passée la crise du coronavirus à quoi
ressemblera le monde d'après vous êtes
nombreux à vous poser la question
emmanuel macron en tout cas l'a laissé
entendre lors de sa dernière allocution
l'économie sortira profondément changé
de cette épidémie souveraineté
indépendance autonomie
le président at il changé de logiciel
vers quel modèle économique se
dirige-t-on on voit cela tout de suite
avec l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques toujours via skype et ce sera
encore le cas pendant toute la durée de
ce confinement jacques oui tout à fait
jusqu'au 11 mai on l'espère
et alors jacques à comment se dessine
donc ce monde d'après cas évoqués
emmanuel macron et bien ses fans il faut
tout d'abord comprendre que la france et
son économie vont sortir très affaibli
de cette crise sanitaire à bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie nous
parle d'un recul de 8% du produit
intérieur brut
gérald darmanin le ministre du budget
prévoit quant à lui un déficit public de
près de 9% de ce même pib c'est dire
l'importance du choc
or ces deux ministres pêche très
probablement encore par optimisme alors
jacques dans quelle mesure justement
est-ce trop optimistes et bien si vous
voulez stéphanie les estimations de
l'insee de la banque de france sur
lesquelles s'appuient en particulier
bruno le maire pour deux mois de
confinement
ce bal sur une contraction de l'économie
d'environ 6 % en année pleine
or les estimations de l'insee et de la
banque de france table sur une baisse de
35% de la production et nous savons
aujourd'hui que le chômage partiel
touchent déjà 44 25 % de l'emploi
salarié
quant à la productivité du travail de
ceux qui travaillent toujours par
exemple en télétravail
elle a visiblement pas mal baissé alors
il faut regarder d'autres estimations
comme celles qui sont faites par la
banque italienne unicredit ou celles qui
ont été faites dans mon propre
laboratoire leucémiques etc
ces différentes estimations indiquent
tout des pertes plus importantes
d'autant plus que l'économie tournera au
ralenti pendant encore plusieurs mois
après la date de déconfinement autrement
dit la récession pour 2020 risque d'être
plus proche de 10% que de 8% alors que
vous l'aviez déjà dit la semaine
dernière effectivement mais cela aura
évidemment des conséquences budgétaires
et oui c'était inévitable c'était
inévitable
d'ailleurs bruno le maire a reconnu que
le gouvernement avait fait le choix de
s'endetter pour sauver l'économie
mais en l'état actuel je crains que l'on
continue de sous-estimer les
conséquences de ce choix
nous avons aussi travaillé sur cette
question oc me et aux dépenses
nécessaires pour soutenir les
entreprises et ces dépenses ne cesse
d'augmenter
60 milliards puis 100 milliards puis 110
milliards et bien vont s'ajouter des
pertes importantes liées à la baisse
d'activité si l'on ajoute que le déficit
qui était déjà inscrit dans la loi de
finances pour 2020 était d'environ à 54
milliards et bien on arrive à un déficit
total pour 2020 d'environ 300 milliards
d'euros c'est à dire à peu près très et
demi pour cent du pib
alors jacques le patron du medef
geoffroy roux de bézieux a provoqué une
polémique en disant qu'il faudrait
travailler plus après le déconfinement
la banque de france elle a parlé d'
austérité du fait de l'ampleur de la
dette publique le monde d'après
verra-t-il un retour à l'austérité du
monde d'avant et c'est vrai le président
du medef et celui de lui et même vous
savez la fédération patronale de la
métallurgie ont choqué en demandant un
assouplissement des règles sur le temps
de travail et sur les congés payés
jusqu'à la fin de 2021 alors devant la
polémique qui a été causé par leurs
propos ils ont reculé et puis il ya ce
qu'a déclaré la banque de france et la
banque de france a indiqué que l'ampleur
de l'endettement conduirait à des
sacrifices à l'avenir prenant ainsi le
contre-pied de ce que font et de ce que
disent bien sûr les autres banques
centrales
alors est-ce que ça annonce le retour
de l'austérité pour l'après épidémie eh
bien on voit que sur ce point
malheureusement la france semble
toujours fidèle à une orthodoxie
monétaire et fiscale que d'autres pays
semblent bien avoir quant à lui
abandonné
alors justement jacques comment les
autres pays dont vous faites allusion
réagi steen sont ces questions alors
stéphanie il est très intéressant de
voir que bien des tabous en fait ont
sauté à l'étranger alors prenons le cas
des états unis la fed la réserve
fédérale rachètent désormais massivement
les des privés y compris d'ailleurs les
mauvaises et les dettes publiques du
gouvernement afin d'éviter bien sûr que
l'économie ne coule
elle annonce ainsi des rachats jusqu'à
2300 milliards de dollars autrement dit
2 3 trillions de dollars c'est une somme
qu'il faut comparer avec le programme de
la banque centrale européenne fameux
programme ppp qui lui plafonne à 1000
milliards d'euros mais le plus
intéressant c'est ce qui se passe au
royaume uni les autorités prévoient là
bas une baisse de 12 à 13% du pipe
ce qui est d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
réaliste que les prévisions de bruno le
maire alors face à cela la banque
d'angleterre là où les dés comme on
l'appelle a annoncé qu'elle financerait
directement le gouvernement
autrement dit qu'elle rachèterait
directement les dettes émises par le
trésor
et cela sans passer par l'intermédiaire
des banques privées c'est une véritable
révolution car l'airé les rachats qui
était d'ailleurs couramment pratiqué
jusqu'au début des années 70 ont été par
la suite interdite et cette interdiction
figure même dans la charte de la banque
centrale européenne alors mes jacques à
qu'est ce que cela nous dit sur le monde
d'après finalement eh bien c'est fini
que ce monde d'après en tous les cas
pour les autres pays que la france
pourrait être effectivement bien
différent du monde d'avant on comprend
bien que les principales économies sont
en train de connaître un choc qui est
aujourd'hui bien supérieur à la crise 2
2008 2009 un choc qui n'est en réalité
comparable qu'à celui de la crise de
1929 et de la grande dépression qui en a
suivi il donc pas étonnant que les
gouvernements regardent désormais les
mesures qui ont été appliqués à l'époque
où à partir de 1945
si l'on veulent encore regarder la
france de l'après guerre alors jacquin
n'est ce pas finalement aussi ce
qu'annonce d'une certaine manière le
discours d' emmanuel macron vous savez
tout à fait raison et de ce point de vue
ni de ce point de vue la fin de
l'allocution d'emmanuel macron était
très intéressant quand le président dit
notre monde sans doute se fragmentera
quand il parle aussi de repartir une
indépendance agricole sanitaire
industrielles et technologiques
françaises
eh bien on croirait entendre le général
de gaulle mais aussi d'ailleurs les
hommes politiques de la quatrième
république comme par exemple pierre
mendès france ou guy mollet quand le
président rappelle les mots de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen vous savez les distinctions
sociales ne peuvent être fondées que sur
l'utilité commune
il mobilise des symboles de notre
histoire qui sont effectivement très
fort enfin quand il dit à la fin de son
discours il nous faudra bâtir une
stratégie où nous retrouverons le temps
long la possibilité de planifier vous
avez bien entendu la possibilité de
planifier et bien on croirait entendre
du jean luc mélenchon dans le texte
alors mes pattes on croire jacques
peuvent sans pardon on le croire sur
parole c'est monotone pas été prononcé
simplement pour faire un petit peu
passer la pilule d'un confinement
prolongée jusqu'au 11 mai bien sûr c'est
fini on peut avoir des doutes
après tout selon la phrase attribuée à
jacques chirac
les promesses n'engagent que ceux qui
les écoutent
mais les réalités de l'économie mondiale
après l'épidémie
vont elles aussi s'imposer à emmanuel
macron les chaînes de production
internationalisé par la mondialisation
sont aujourd'hui considérés comme
beaucoup trop fragiles en cas de
perturbations majeures comme celle que
nous connaissons
il faudra donc nécessairement
relocaliser de même la pénurie de
masques de tests de médicaments de
respirateurs que nous connaissons montre
aussi que l'on ne peut plus dépendre
exclusivement des importations il faudra
donc rebâtir un outil de production
nationale et l'industrie
réindustrialiser la france et cela il
faut tout de suite le dira nous ne sera
pas possible sans un minimum de
protectionnisme alors pour faire tout
cela il faudra bien s'émanciper de
nombreuses règles et directives de
l'union européenne
retrouvez aussi notre souveraineté
monétaire est effectivement mettre en
oeuvre une forme de planification
stratégique
ces mesures sont les conséquences de la
démondialisation qui est aujourd'hui en
marche
si on peut dire en conclusion jacques
selon-vous emmanuel macron saura-t-il et
sortons pourra-t-il s'adapter à ce
nouveau monde
oui il a dit qu'il devrait se réinventer
et c'est une excellente question que
vous posez c'est fanny parce que pour
ceux là pour justement de se réinventer
il lui faudrait mettre ses bottes dans
les pas de l'opposition la plus radicale
celle qui va de mélenchon à marine le
pen
et ça ça semble très peu vraisemblable
à tout le moins emmanuel macron a d'une
certaine façon et il fait il faut bien
le dire dans son discours légitimer les
propos de ses opposants les plus
radicaux
avec ce discours il a aussi suscité des
espoirs immenses et pas seulement quand
à l'annoncé d'une date de déconfinement
11 mai et naturellement il sera jugé sur
pièce merci jacques évidemment toujours
des réflexions qui nous font analyser
mieux la situation et nous font nous
poser encore plus de questions merci à
vous